hello everybody
welcome to the live oh stupid thing
tilt up
there you go it's going to be a big day
today
uh we're going to be doing an end-to-end
longitudinal demo with our cto harold
it's going to be great
we're also going to be announcing a
video contest that all of you can
participate in even if you have a comma
2 or a comma 3.
but first off something very exciting
hi sam welcome everybody
something very exciting right here
these boxes right here are the final
comma threes that were in our backlog
meaning we're fully caught up
and we have comma threes in stock now
for the first time ever
ah these are all boxes for comma threes
thousands of them
boxes everywhere
welcome everybody
i'll say this we've shipped over 500
comma threes now which is a huge
milestone super awesome
uh very proud of the production team for
all the hard work they've been doing
let's actually go take a quick peek
at uh some of the assembly going on here
so over here are some finished uh comma
three skeletons they just need the back
cases on them
and the screens so i mean they're gonna
be ready to go on stress tests later
today
over here we got some
parts laid out
and over here
one is uh
making one right now check it out
gets a little quiet on fridays uh
because
everyone comes in very early and leaves
very early uh in the production team
but uh yeah we got a full house back
there working on comma threes and we
have some ready to ship so if you buy a
comma 3 today expect to see a shipping
notification on monday
which is super great and here's some on
the stress test we've already taken a
bunch of them off
um
yeah brevin you did talk to one at
comic-con he was
he was there on the booth but yeah here
are all these beautiful
comma threes
they all look great i love the test
because we can
check out all the cameras
in full screen super cool
so that's the narrow camera
that's the 185 degree rear camera
and the 185 degree front camera
and something that people haven't seen
before yet is this
uh new contraption that we've built
it actually is just a 45 degree angled
mirror
so when we're testing camera focus
it shows the roof
so you can see there's the roof and we
use those lines to check the focus on
all the devices
so that is great so we don't have any
devices with bad focus going out there
and yeah we've been doing that
practically the whole time but let's
announce the video contest
i think some of you are here for this
most of you are here for the end to end
longitudinal demo it's very very early
days with that but this video contest is
very exciting
all right we're going to set this thing
up like a tripod
so i don't know how many people know
where i'm from
but i used to be doing
open pilot videos on my personal channel
before i got hired at comma so back in
2018
they did a video contest where they
asked people to describe what openpilot
was
and
that's what i did i made a video entered
the contest myself i was in montreal at
the time
and i won which is hilarious
so
you know it's funny that i'm announcing
the video contest here
three years later
um
but yeah this was can you believe back
in 2018 we had a giraffe
a panda
and an eon
look they were all separate they weren't
all integrated
into the beautiful car harness we have
today
so
back then
i remember mr cole also had a great
video back in that contest
back then when i won this contest i got
500
so
alex thought of the brilliant idea to
adjust for inflation
so
the winner of this video contest
let's see what they're gonna make
well they're gonna get 544.46
nice and there's actually going to be
two winners
so let me talk about the first category
that you could win and by the way this
video contest is gonna last for two
weeks
so your time starts now you have two
weekends to do it and after the two
weekends we're gonna come back here to
judge uh the videos
on a live in two weeks from today
so
first category
is uh comma three
you know there's over 500 people who
have comma threes now and this is the
category for you if you have one of
those devices
uh so basically what we want
is we want to you know hear from you
hear what you think about the device
and how you like it
so i you know i'm sure a lot of you love
your comma threes a lot of you upgraded
from comma two devices
you know tell us in a video
why that is what you like about the
comma three what you're excited about
there's a lot of exciting things in the
future for the common three you know
such as end-to-end longitudinal is a a
dream that we're working on research
uh so yeah there's a lot of
exciting things stop lines that some of
you may have seen our tweets on stop
lines
uh essentially anytime a human stops
the model is going to predict a stop
line so
it's not working super
100 of the time yet which is why we're
not shipping it yet but we're working on
it and if that works we're gonna have
red light stop signs on comma three
uh yeah george isn't in the office today
so that's category one just talk about
those were your tweets js
you know you might be able to win one of
these uh win this video contest
[Laughter]
so
that is the first main goal that's the
main uh event if you have a comma three
i recommend entering
in that contest just talk about it you
know make review video on it do whatever
you want
let's talk about some creators on the
platform
that are making great stuff already
that's me
[Laughter]
logan legrand of course i'm sure many of
you know logan's videos he makes a lot
of great stuff and he made a great
comparison video of common three versus
comma two
so he might have a good chance of
winning this if he ends up making
something
um
you know there's a lot of people who are
just making some good videos
just showing their like daily commutes
i think these are great videos and we
definitely would consider one of these
just like talking about your experience
the comma 3 and and how it helps driving
you know here's someone named comma
drive doing a great video this isn't a
comma three so they can't win that
category but harold's gonna talk about
the next category and of course there's
uh let it drive who's been doing some
great content as well also might be able
to win that other category
cool
so thank you to everybody making content
on the platform
all right now we're going to go talk to
harold
our cto he's going to explain the second
one keep in mind both of these if you
win in your category get 544.46
which you could use towards a comma 3 if
you want
or for anything
harold
yes hello hello hello guys i have to go
go this way for the mic
all right what's our second category
that anyone can enter in if they have a
comma device well the second category is
just uh videos of laneless
to doing impressive things just
impressive end-to-end lateral uh lateral
things with open pilot for those of you
who don't drive with laneless if you uh
turn on the toggle in settings
it'll uh
it'll dry up end to end it'll try to
mimic human driving behavior
and uh that can lead to a lot cooler and
smoother uh lateral control than uh than
using the lane lines which is by default
um i saw your scene popped in there yeah
um
well yeah i think uh i think that's uh
it's our biggest achievement at research
is uh getting good lateral control by uh
just learning from human driving and so
you guys can make some content uh
showing that would be great we can uh go
for a drive now as well and uh yeah just
do some end-to-end driving and see let's
do it
let's see how it goes
um
yeah so you know you think of my uh the
laneless video i made just showing that
unique behavior at an exit those are the
kind of little subtle things that
laneless does really well
and we're going to have a new video
coming out soon about lane lists going
through intersections which i think it
does amazing at intersections it's the
reason why if the intersection curves
will still uh predict the correct thing
and go through the intersection
all right
going in the civic ready
we have a traffic light in the office
yes we do
it works now right harold yeah it works
the traffic light will go red if the
tests are broken so uh
immediately start stressing out if you
see like a big red red glow in the
hallway
yep
keeps you on your toes
here's the comma three looks so
beautiful look at that all right so this
is uh
go driving with
that allows us to get very smooth policy
without ever really manually you know
writing anything about how to take a
turn or how to uh how to go through an
intersection but it ends up being super
smooth
and uh we want to do the same thing for
longitudinal and so that's a that's a
whole project and and the start of that
is just uh
having some some end to end on the on
the device and uh seeing how it does so
it says here the the red stop light
should stop here
and
yep come check that stop
so that's fully end to end um
it's now stopped at the stop light and
the
red stop light is probably not in view
so it's not going to see when it turns
green it's probably just going to be
stopped here forever so we'll take over
whenever it turns green
but this is just kind of a proof of
concept to show that the model does
understand certain things uh about
longitudinal just from understanding how
humans drive
so um light turned green i took over
again
here we'll come behind the stopped car
and it should come to a smooth
human-like stop and that felt very human
yeah it seems
yeah so this is the thing about the end
to end stuff is uh you know we've been
working quite a long time on you know
just like lead policy and that kind of
stuff and and there's still a lot of
things about it that don't seem that
smooth or that enjoyable and a lot of
that's just because it's very hard to
hand tune that um you know it's all
these different situations different
types of you know accelerating and
braking are more smooth um but it's hard
to hand code that but if you just tell
it to drive like a human like i didn't
take over for this turn i just helped
the steering a little bit
and i mean it's very human-like
and hopefully by using this kind of
machine learning and by mimicking the
human behavior we can just start getting
longitudinal policies that keep
improving as our models improve as
opposed to us like having to hand code
you know all these new situations
and here it's accelerating behind this
lead
one of the issues we have with the
normal lead policy is that
it doesn't appropriately accelerate when
a lead car pulls away or
it it'll accelerate too hard if you're
just slowly trying to come up to crew
speed that's just because it's not very
aware of like context and stuff
and so hopefully by leveraging the
end-to-end output we can improve that
i just took over here because the model
wasn't going to see that you were making
a turn so i probably wouldn't have dealt
with that very smoothly
here we're going to go on the highway
see how it does here so this is uh now
end-to-end longitudinal and end-to-end
lateral control the mole is just doing
what it thinks a human would and we'll
see how it goes someone said
pre-recorded
it's definitely not recorded i'm sure
we'll see several instances
of that manifesto
this is our torque modded honda civic
with a pedal right
uh with a pedal yeah yeah
so as you can see it gets a lot closer
to the leads than uh the normal policy
would that's not exactly what we want
out of it but i mean this is just part
of you know this experimental stuff just
to kind of see what it wants to do and
see how that goes
um but yeah this is uh kind of the first
run of this we haven't really worked on
any kind of
end-to-end longitudinal
[Music]
yeah this is the start
again so speed control here is being
done by the model um
there is some limits to
how close we get to a lead because
sometimes we get uncomfortably close so
i put some limit in there but that's not
really what's causing the following
distance
now it's really just doing uh doing what
the model wants at this point
and hopefully we'll uh we'll be able to
do some slow down for exit soon and
you'll kind of see that the model has
some basic understanding of what's going
on
yeah everyone's saying it looks very
chill yeah here it's very uh getting
quite close here so i'm not sure it's
gonna slow down the time yeah i'll just
slow down myself for that one yeah as
you can see it's still definitely not
pre-recorded uh dell definitely makes
plenty of mistakes more of a proof of
concept than anything else
yes so unlike end to end longitudinal
end-to-end lateral is already very good
and you can you know enable it on your
own device today and give it a shot so
you know i think that's what i really
want to see in these uh videos that
people are making is just show it doing
cool stuff because it it does every day
like you know we drive it every day and
it does really amazing
um you know really human-like turns and
things like that
yeah exactly i mean uh the end-to-end
lateral stuff it's kind of
state-of-the-art machine learning and
self-driving stuff but uh i mean you can
experience it just the same way we do
like it's the state of the art but it's
also shipped so you know i don't need
the stuff we use at home is exactly the
same as what's uh what's on the public
branches so
you want to see the state of the article
we're working on just install uh install
open pilot yeah
and enable the lane those things
should be just as magical as what we use
internally
there's no secret good open pilot you
can just try it on your own device
someone asks when enter and uh lateral
is moving to beta
lateral yes oh i see like i guess the
default yeah toggle so one of the big
issues we have with the
end-to-end lateral is
it's it's a little bit less robust so if
you would move a little bit too much to
the left or too much to the right um
it's not going to recover very quickly
um
and so what that means is that if
there's errors in controls like if and
and what's happening what we have the
problem we're trying to fix is that if
you're in bank turns just the way the
vehicle dynamics works is you're going
to slide a little bit down the back of
the road into the turn
um
and this effect exists both with lane
lines and with laneless but it's
stronger with laneless because of the
less recovery pressure so we're trying
to fix that so the cars are robust to
that and once that's fixed then i think
overall lane should just be much better
than with lane lines so hopefully that's
that's all we need to do
yeah
so that's when uh that toggle might
change to be default yeah exactly
someone asked when this is planned if
it's planned for a 1.0 or later what is
the end-to-end longitudinal stuff
[Music]
i got first let me talk about the
contests one more time because alex came
in so basically we have two categories
for all those watching who are just
tuning in
the first category is comma three
related so you know anything uh about
your comma three like a review of it how
it compares to your previous comma two
those videos would be really great and
obviously the higher quality of the
video the more chance you could win
so that's category one and then category
two is anything about
uh using lane lists on your common
device so that can be you know an eon a
comma two or a comma three
and uh yeah just showing off cool stuff
that
the driving model does on laneless mode
which is when it has this red
line that's how you can tell it's on
lane list mode
and uh you know it does a lot of cool
stuff
it goes through intersections it takes
exits very human like you can see an
example video on our channel right now
uh something cool that lanelist does
that's the kind of video we're looking
for just like showing off some cool
laneless stuff
so
and both of those categories the prize
is
544.46 which is 500 from 2018 adjusted
for inflation
so
if you'll make a video harold
does this count maybe i don't know if
this counts maybe if i find something
cool
[Music]
yes yeah one of the type of things
yeah i think that's most impressive you
know when it's going through
intersections and makes correct
decisions
uh that you know any any naive policy
with lane lines wouldn't do
i mean it continues to amaze me how
you know we don't really tell it
anything or don't really specifically
tell them all to do anything but it just
it can it can make things just seem so
super humanly smooth just by
making human driving it's pretty it's
pretty astonishing yeah this is amazing
yeah we can uh we want to get on off
rank here and see if uh yeah he's gonna
slow down
sure let's try it
so i did notice that uh i was trying to
make some tweaks that i would respect
the leads for the
cruise speed but it doesn't seem to be
doing that at all so
there might be some disengages here but
uh let's see we're gonna go off the off
ramp here let's see what it does about
it it still seems to be going very fast
let's help it out a little bit slow down
a little bit here because that's a
little bit too extreme yes
so we'll see how it does here whether it
uh
yeah it's a little bit a little bit late
on the break today
i have to give it another chance early
days early days early days for sure
good uh forward collision warning that
the model did though
yeah that's that was a model for
collision warning there so it uh it goes
off if it predicts very hard brakes so
uh
so that part works
that's good let's see let's see if
there's anything interesting
so
here
mean you can see the stop and go and the
way it leaves from the from the light
soul you know that's that's relatively
human kind of stuff so that's cool well
that was neat you were engaged during
that turn and it
held
12 miles an hour while you were turning
and now you went straight it's picking
it up all right so we got a traffic
light coming up there with no lead we'll
see uh we'll see if it thinks that's an
important thing to stop for
i hope so
[Music]
oh
check that out
wow it hesitates that's impressive but
uh there we go wow oh and green well
that's our view it's out of view
yeah so one of the things that's still
holding this back is you know it's it's
a lot of the
the lights and stop signs are out of
view when you're at them so
the water kind of gets there then stops
and then it kind of loses context so
yeah we're gonna have to it doesn't seem
to want to go very fast in this road she
doesn't like this road just i think
maybe uphill is uh maybe a little bit
lazy
yeah
yeah hopefully we can uh increase the
view soon and then those those
become more context aware of that kind
of stuff
do you guys have any questions about uh
just intern lateral in general anything
about that or anything yeah let us know
any any questions about the contest what
kind of videos you make that is all
fair game
uh someone asked what branch this is on
you know highly experimental yeah
extremely fine you probably shouldn't be
using it you know that's a good point
because i like that
no this is a
it's purely an experimental branch that
just kind of
allows us to do some very basic tests on
yeah learn what the model knows right
yeah i mean in general we don't really
do any real world testing for this kind
of stuff we try to write very
comprehensive test suite so that we can
simulate all the behavior but every now
and again you kind of have to evaluate
that the simulator behavior is similar
to the real world behavior so that's
really all we would ever do real world
testing for
you know for anything practical we we
kind of only train a test in the
simulator it's just
the iteration time is so much faster
it's it's reproducible and we can keep
pushing on that kind of stuff
uh increase the view someone said sounds
like wait for comma four the comma three
can see 360 degrees yeah coma 3 can see
plenty it's just a matter of uh
you know we have to write the model and
make
sure that it's better we've done
experiments in the past and we actually
didn't get any benefits from increasing
the view size so that's why we're uh
we're not really pushing on that right
now because uh there were still other
bottlenecks holding back the performance
of the model but once it's clear that
increasing the view will be the next
thing to do then then we'll work on that
and shift that yes
data bugs in the training and ground
truth seem to be most of uh
most of our problems most of the time so
someone was asking how do you
get it to
stop for red lights and stop signs
if it was already end to end before i
think you're confusing n10 lateral and
longitudinal so we've had end to end
lateral as this toggle for a while but
antenna longitudinal is
understanding uh fully end to end the
gas and the brakes that humans do right
yeah yeah exactly so we've shipped i
mean behind the toggle it it does
basically drive fully end to end for
lateral
um and so that's basically just
mimicking the human driving uh but for
longitudinal what's currently shipped is
still just using lead cars and
and like the crew speed and just some
really basic logic
but we want to make that more
intelligent too so that it can
eventually stop at stop signs and stop
lights and it can slow down for turns
and it's just a it's a pretty big
project and it's something we're just
like starting to really work on and
working through all that yeah stuff a
lot of people asking if it'll resume at
green if it's in the model box that's
the the goal right i mean in theory yeah
it's in the model box we're not quite
sure what we're going to do with stop
lines yet so stop lines will probably be
like the first kind of feature that's in
this end-to-end longitudinal kind of
group of things that will ship and
well we'll have to do some experiments
and see what the what the best approach
is there hopefully resume a green and
then the stop signs i mean resuming is
not that easy there so we're not quite
sure what we're going to do
yeah like again uh
i guess to submit a video for the
contest uh you know tweet it at us or
use hashtag openpilot on your video
and uh just title it with openpilot and
if it's uploaded in the next few weeks
i'm gonna assume it's for the contest so
you know peruse youtube and uh yeah just
upload the video to youtube
you know explaining what you're doing
make sure you know it says open pilot
somewhere or comma three so i can find
it
so you know that's the goal and uh yeah
for
you know 544
that's uh you know you're on your way to
afford a comma three if you sell your
comma two that's another you know five
hundred dollars you could get a comma
three for like half off if you win the
contest and sell your
old hardware good start this is a good
start
um
not sure if there's much uh
else to say
yeah more
anything else we should talk about let's
see if there's another thing yeah here's
another light let's uh let's see what it
wants to do
oh and it's it's feeling like it's ready
oh there it is there it goes
wow
all righty came to a smooth stop at this
light that's exactly where i would have
stopped too yeah it's right at the so
yeah this is uh the power of machine
learning we didn't tell anything we just
said drive like human
and here it is
it's driving like a human yeah
pretty magical one if it would actually
see the light someone would go and
yeah
i think it would though because i mean
just of how uh
how clearly it seemed to see the
difference you know rather than the
green lights and probably
if it was in the view it'd probably
react immediately yeah i think you're
right
we've also got some uh some exciting
updates to uh driver monitoring coming
yes there was some uh notice there was
some
performance with masked users that
wasn't that great
and uh wishing our driver monitoring
team has been
working on making sure the the models
also understand how masks work and that
masks don't uh
don't ruin the performance of drive
monitoring so hopefully that will work
out and we'll have some exciting updates
for you
um by zero eight ten
that was a little late breaking that
yeah very comfortable
a lot of people being like what about
humans with road rage the whole
the whole point of uh
you know end to end is it's like
like it's it's like everybody's driving
right like i don't know how to explain
that yeah i mean i do the crazy stuff
yeah
i mean i think that's a common uh i mean
it's an intuitive thought to have about
that right is you know if you just drive
like humans then you're never gonna be
better than humans but i think uh i
don't think that's true so
you would only we drive like the the
model only learns to drive like the the
mean human or the me the median of the
distribution so
um
outlier behavior like aggressive driving
or kind of swerving around in the lanes
kind of shouldn't be the behavior that
the model learns to imitate um that's
one part so we kind of expect the
the me like the median of the
distribution to be much better i mean
you can kind of imagine it though as
don't think of like asking just a random
person to drive and see if you like that
driving behavior but ask a hundred or a
thousand people to in every situation
say how they would behave and then just
take like the average or the most common
answer and
then you should kind of exclude all
these kind of outliers which are like
maybe too aggressive or
too conservative or just generally
mistakes and weird that's one part and
the other part is we can also kind of
steer it a little bit means we can
selectively use conservative drivers
maybe for follow distance and stuff like
that but i mean we're really not there
yet driving like a human or like the
average human would be
not just better than open pilot is today
but better than any self-driving system
is anywhere in the world so
um i think
that's that's not really a
not really a reason to not try to
imitate human driving
yeah that was a good discussion i i saw
the person who said that it was like
joking but it's still a good discussion
a lot of people genuinely have that
question um yeah i think it's unfair if
you say you know drive like a human we
all wanted it to be better than humans
right but i think
you think there's a clear path to get to
superhuman by learning from humans
yes
uh someone said sorry joining late
is end-to-end long focused on
slow down for turns and red lights and
stop signs or more advanced things like
follow distance
speed based on the scene etc
um
antoinette long just means
uh you know
end to end all the time for all
longitudinal control
which will be uh which includes all
those things which is you know stopping
at stop signs it's better smarter lead
policy
but we we wouldn't be able to ship it
like that probably for a variety of
reasons so probably you just want the
models to understand how to behave like
a human for end-to-end longitudinal and
then we can take parts of that and try
to ship those like for example stop
lines is one example of just a part of
the longitudinal policy that we can try
to ship or maybe just smart follow
distance that kind of stuff
yeah so it's the beginning it's the
start and eventually there'll be a
toggle once it's you know in a state
where we want we feel like it's it's
good enough to to try out just like and
then lateral right now is in a good
state to try out
uh so
it's gonna be a bit for
a toggle like that to come to your
device but we just wanted to give a
taste on the future
uh because the future is
winning yeah and it's coming the future
is coming yes oh yeah i just thought you
know it's good for people to see what
we're working on you know we're not
we're not just sitting idly by we're
trying things we're working on it and um
try to make it as good as we can as fast
as we can yeah
yeah and uh
some people keep asking about like what
about all the cars that you know don't
have radar that you know like like the
accord for example i think
you know part of research right is is
working on some sort of fully vision
only
solution for those vehicles right yeah
so i mean we've been
i mean i've been trying to do stuff with
vision on the acc
so far there's still some issues the the
model is really not that good at
understanding that a car is slowing down
in front of you if the brake lights
aren't on
and that's still kind of a blocker
radar is very very good at knowing the
exact speed of the car in front of you
so that's
a very easy way to know if the leads are
slowing down and you can be very
proactive in how you drive because of
that
um
and so far we're still struggling to get
the same things from vision but the hope
is that you know humans can dry just
looking at the camera so the model
should be able to drive just fine too
it's just a matter of
of writing the algorithm that uses the
data correctly and this is also part of
why we're
working on the end-to-end longitudinal
stuff it really allows us to make sure
the model understands as much as
possible about the scene that's relevant
to longitudinal behavior and then we can
uh you know use that
to tweak the policy or at least guide
our efforts if the end-to-end policy
also has trouble with slowing down for
uh
lead cards that just started breaking
then we know we need to work on on the
model just understanding the scene
rather than just the policy
cool yeah and we do have an accord now
uh
and i'm sure we'll start using uh vision
only to be testing it out yeah coming
weeks and uh
yeah
uh fred asks why end to end likes to hug
corners that's the thing harold talked
about before where uh
you're better at explaining it than me
that's something you're working to fix
though yeah i mean most of the time if
it's hugging corners it's because most
turns on highways are banked is to make
it easier to drive around them and bank
turns cause you to kind of slip into the
turn um so they they kind of make the
car turn by itself even if you weren't
turning the steering wheel um and that's
not something that we compensate for
well in open pilot so we want to make
open pilot understand that the road is
banked and have the controls of the
vehicle steering correct for that so
that it's not turning more than the
model ever wanted to which is what's
happening now
hopefully if we fix that then it won't
do that anymore yeah
yeah i know if you notice that's on you
know non-bank roads it's like very very
very good
yeah so we'll get there
and that's probably when the toggle will
go away if it's it's good enough
cool yeah um just to
do a quick
you know recap on uh the contest for
those people who are
interested
oh
look at that we just turned on
navigation
if it works
i don't know
yeah look at that
so
navigation is just uh purely directions
so far but
you know eventually that's the start to
something big
now be on open pilot in the future
um
let's see someone asked have you trained
on comma three data yet
yeah so the model that's uh now in
master that we're hoping to release that
one is train on comma free data
it took us a little bit of time to get
that up and running but
yes and so far no models have uh
are trained on the wide camera for combo
3.
so that'll you know maybe be in the
future
yeah
we're just chilling
yeah i don't know we saw some uh i don't
know if we could do a slowdown for a
turn
i don't know this is kind of a random
drive i don't know where we're going
but we stopped for some uh some red
lights smoothly so i hope that's uh
i don't know gives us some some hope
that uh at least the end-to-end models
at least understand that red lights are
something to stop for green lights or
something you shouldn't stop for so it's
uh it's the start of a big
longitudinal project
yes and uh yeah the stop lines branch
you know kind of works
and that's kind of works i'd say it
works a little better than than this but
also it's less fully end to end so that
makes sense yeah this is a much more
experimental yes
uh so yeah i mean you can you know try
out the stop lines branch if you want to
and it'll probably stop for most red
lights and stop signs
pretty cool stuff
uh yeah so just to
you know reiterate uh we got a video
contest going on the way to enter is you
just upload a video to youtube uh with
hashtag openpilot
or just name it like comma three open
pilot and uh you have two weeks from
today to make your videos
and after the two weeks we're gonna
judge them
you know probably have alex here and you
know a d maybe some
diversity in the judging panel
we'll get some voting we can get the
cards yeah
we'll watch them at lunch or something
um so there's two categories first
category is comma three so for all those
over 500 people who have comma threes
let us know how it is you know you can
do a review video on it talk about the
nav if you want not many people talk
about the nav but
i mean it works it's pretty cool you can
input a destination on your phone and
then uh
over lte it just pops right onto the
comma three
so that's a cool feature not many people
know about
uh so that's category one just anything
about the comma three how you like it
how it compares to the comma 2 in your
opinion
any of that stuff is fair game second
category is laneless lateral control
which means you know the steering
control so
you put on that toggle that lets you
disable the use of lane lines you're in
end-to-end lateral mode and it does some
pretty cool stuff now you can see an
example of those kinds of videos on this
very channel
uh in the
video i made
so coming out to another red light here
let's see how it does it's slowing down
look at that
it's a little bit far but it's
delayed for the stop line at least
that's pretty
not cool this up it's real
it's not very reliable but that's that's
the start that's the start now we just
iron out the bugs yes and yes uh
correct mark the second category is for
anybody you can have an e on comma two
or comma three uh
you can you know just run
uh the uh laneless toggle and you can
make a video on laneless you don't have
to have a comma three but on the comma
three one i think you should have come
through yeah
yes uh and they're now shipping that's
the big news they're now shipping
limited stock right now so you know if
you buy one right now i can guarantee
we're gonna ship it on monday but if you
don't buy it now you know we'll see
you might have to start having a wait
list again a little weightless get in
before the other people do yes uh so
yeah we've gotten through all the
backlog everyone's gonna get their
comment threes in the mail the next few
days who uh was still in the backlog
so it's very exciting stuff
uh a lot of people are loving their
comma threes it's just such a huge
improvement over a comma two
visually i mean it's just like a real
piece of hardware super cool so you'll
definitely love it if you end up getting
a comment three
uh yeah the big model will let us see
traffic lights um that are currently out
of the model box view so
you definitely are gonna need big model
before we can resume from green lights
and stuff like that for that reason yeah
uh so that's something you know we'll
we'll do if it makes sense we'll
definitely end up doing yeah we've we've
spent some time on this already it's
just a matter of you know going through
and making sure that it actually
improves things we don't really want to
spend time on it until we've figured out
the other bottlenecks i think that's
going to happen soon
yeah i do too
um is there anything more questions yeah
any last-minute
questions
silence took some several wrong turns i
think yeah
we're in convoy streets i'm glad you
know where we are
i'm glad you know where we are there's
no discount code on comma threes they're
extremely limited we can't offer a
discount on them because we don't have
any in stock anyway
we have some in stock buy them now but
uh
you know they're they're very
limited they're very custom fully custom
made so
they take a lot of effort to build and
perfect
and if you're wondering how good the
comma threes are gonna be just think
about how good the comma two is now
versus when it launched and just
extrapolate those improvements for the
year and a half two years and uh
i mean hopefully uh you know imagining
some good things yeah i think people
forget
what state open pilot was in when the
comma 2 launched
you know it was like
you know it kind of worked there's no
end to end lateral at all that's all a
new development
it was a lot less reliable the
software's gotten way more reliable we
added auto lane change that didn't exist
on the common two cameras we got auto
lane change we got
yeah the end-to-end lateral stuff's
really big it's huge huge improvements
yes the stability went up so much
hopefully it'll keep coming yes
so yeah if you think about that
phantom breaking kind of eliminated that
yeah mostly uh
cut in detection was also
cutting detection
someone said open pile was pretty mad
when i got my comma one
or my wave one comma two it's
ridiculously better since then exactly
yes
i'm excited to hear the
the list of things we've achieved over
the next uh over the lifetime common
threes as well yes
all right
well i guess we'll head out y'all can
start working on your videos and uh yeah
i'll write up a little thing on the
discord that just kind of explains
everything in a brief paragraph that you
can check out
um yeah for those people asking about
reliability we're going to be writing up
a reliability post and doing some
content on that we just need the comma
3s to be out for a few months
so we have some statistics but then the
deep is going to work on a great
reliability post
but yeah common threes you know they're
all new components
they're all made of very high quality
components
you know no used chinese phone so
uh yeah i think you can extrapolate what
i'm saying with that information
all right
so yeah we'll see you all we'll do it
live at some point i mean we'll
definitely see you in two weeks at the
very least yeah sounds good if you guys
have anything content you want or
anything specific you want to know more
about that you want us to talk about
please let us know
yeah i've got a blog post coming as well
that kind of just explains how open
pilot works in case people want to
tinker with it or understand it better
we'll try to get out more content like
that yep and uh yeah some more content
you know we'll do some vision only acc
content we'll do some sonata long
content because uh
works with open pilot now if you have a
configuration changed and uh yeah more
more laneless stuff
all right see you guys bye